let's start with you first of all why do
you think that home secretary's plans
will succeed where were previous plans
that seem very similar to a lot of
critics haven't I think a lot of time
has been taken when it comes to the
drafting of this bill I think the the
wording of the way it's framed I think
is is very clear uh what the government
are intending from this bill and if it
goes through Parliament what Parliament
you're intending from his bill so I
think that I'm hopeful is is less
vulnerable uh to Legal Challenge from
the nationality and board but do you
think it'll work
um yes I mean I think if it works I
think if it works it's intended it will
work and I think it will provide a
deterrent and I think it's necessary you
know I hear from my constituents all the
time how angry and frustrated they are
about these Small Boat Crossings and I
think a deterrent is vital and I think
this would provide it Nia it's that it's
that deterrent element isn't it which is
the thing that the government thinks is
crucial to this bill perhaps less so
than the nuts and bolts why do you think
it won't work I think the problem is
that there has been an abject failure by
the story government to tackle the
problem and it's got to be multifaceted
how you tackle the problem we've said
for example strengthening the
cross-border policing that's really
important we're getting better
agreements with safe countries we had a
Dublin agreement and we're in the EU we
don't have that now we need a proper
agreement so that people coming from
safe countries can be safely returned we
also as we've called for
um for months now need to make sure the
people from Albania go back because it
is a safe country but we also need
genuine safe routes which work we know
there are people who tragically were
left in Afghanistan in the scramble
there was back in August 2021 who are
still unable to get out although they're
supposed to be a process that process is
not working and we need to get those
safe routes set up as well as of course
you know tackling the criminal gangs
Prosecuting them many of them actually
live in the UK and could be prosecuted
again a failure by government and of
course tackling the backlog 160 000
applications needing to be processed
people at the taxpayers expense in
hotels when they could actually be
paying tax and contributing to our
economy if it's deemed that they are
appropriate to stay here David there
hasn't been a pretty scathing of the
government's plans yesterday in
Parliament what about labors would you
back those well I think part of the
problem here is that everybody talks
about stopping the boards actually I'd
like to see is let's stop by politics
here let's make sure that we've got safe
and legal routes so that people can come
here I think one of the other questions
I would have is the fact that the
legislation that is clearly not
compatible with International what
thrashes the refugee convention it
trashes the international law and I
think what we need to do is get those
safe and legal Works in place and
actually look at the fact that I
remember was on this very Channel this
morning
challenges that come from this
legislation let's be honest this
legislation is all about creating a wage
issue for the next election is about
pitting people against each other and
actually what it's about doing is is
targeting some of the most vulnerable
people in the face of this planet people
who are you know been fleeing War famine
sexual violence it's International
women's day today and what we're talking
about is pathetic legislation that is
cruel is inhumane Scotland is a country
that welcomes refugees not dog whistle
politics that we see from the two main
parties here at Westminster Tom do you
think that there is there is a fair
criticism in the sense of the the tone
of this announcement there were
um comments made in the Commons
yesterday about the language that is
being used
um do you think the government should be
framing this slightly differently well I
mean they've got to they've got to
communicate what they're bringing
forward and that they've communicated uh
the merits of the bill they brought
forward I haven't seen any uh dog
whistle politics um in Parliament that
I'm aware of when it comes to the safe
and legal Roots what's really
interesting is it appears that you know
both opposition parties would have would
be uncapped because we're going to put a
cap on a number of refugees we have as a
country I think that the main party
opposed that cap is also interested to
know that it would appear that the late
party now support an amnesty for illegal
immigrants I think that's quite
interesting it's also his point about
it's also it's also um
they'd come here illegally from a safe
country
you said they're feeling persecution
they're fleeing France they've been
through multiple safe European countries
where they've refused to claim usage
there's lots of things
there's an illegal immigrant so there's
no legal refugees they're not refugees
they're coming from France
illegal immigrants here so I think the
point about dog with politics is that
yesterday we heard far more time being
spent trying to denigrate labor and then
the great Labor's policies instead of
actually explaining what the government
your government I don't think it's
unreasonable for us to ask questions
your opposition party you want to be in
government that's not unreasonable for
us not in the needless way like you've
just done now in the way the needless
way the needless way in the sense that
you've tried to denigrate
um anything to do with us and anything
that we do or say rather than not
actually considering what you're doing
because let's be honest prime minister's
questions too many times it turns into
some signing match from soon rather than
watching the lessons
Tom the point that both but both Nia and
David made is that the government hasn't
really set out safe and clear legal
routes and and you know the home
secretaries where she talked to any of
the the refugee organizations they would
all say that that that for them is the
key issue and we saw government
committees that have examined this issue
say to the government actually it's safe
and legal that is the key issue in terms
of getting people here safely what is
the government doing about that well
actually when you look at the numbers of
refugees you've taken as a country over
the last few years I think there's been
impressive numbers but I think the key
thing is here a lot of these
organizations calling for safe and legal
routes they don't support any kind of
cap so effectively it would be anyone
who wants to move here and claims to be
he was able to move it there's a limit
to how many we can take the difference
between having no cap and not letting
anyone in through safe and legal Roots
isn't there and and that I think that
there are there are safer legal routes I
mean look at look at how many refugees
have come to this country from Hong Kong
from UK 22 from Afghanistan
how many have come from Afghanistan over
the last few years huge numbers of
government Afghanistan 22 in the last
year at all but we talked about the last
few years I mean do you know how many
have come from Afghanistan the last few
years
more frankly because what we're seeing
in Afghanistan is that increasingly
worrying humanitarian situation and for
your party to sit here in the Palace of
Westminster and use refugees as some
sort of political football for the next
general election is frankly despicable
these are vulnerable people Scotland
welcomes refugees and we don't want
anything actually the numbers of
Scottish councils welcome refugees
actually isn't very good sort of
spectrum have the highest number of
asylums because
um Scott City Scotland so I will give
you all work source for my conservative
speakers
refugees and reptile Society we should
not be using them as a political
football the point here because we've
had we've had I've been attacked for
questioning Labor's policy on this but
you know I think most of the people in
this country want to have controlled
immigration at the moment you've got a
leader he's on record when he was a
lawyer saying that that all immigration
law has undercurrents of racism I think
it's legitimate for a public to know
that right you want to be in government
why am I unable to question the labor
party's position on this of course
inflating lots of different major
conflating issue of refugees you're
completing the issue of managed
migration in terms of you know the
economy you've got Business Leaders
calling out for certain job skills which
we don't have so they're totally
finished
if somebody if somebody would like to to
move here um to to work here that's
that's a great that's great that they
want to do that they should engage with
our points-based legal immigration
system they shouldn't arrive here
illegally yeah
somebody who deals a key so I can do
with the home office the backlogs
you're giving me you're giving me
impression okay you're giving me
impression but you actually have no
problem with these and legal Crossings
and actually you think they should be
encouraged Scotland's problem has never
been immigration it's been immigration
and frankly with the conservative
government and control immigration
policy it continues to handle okay David
Nia and Tom we're going to pause it
there I sense that we're not going to
get any agreement on this issue between
the three of you uh but thank you very
much for exploring some of those points
uh it's actually political Editor to
some coaches here with me and Sam it was
passionate and emotional in the Commons
yesterday and we're seeing it here again
in the studio now this is something that
people care very very clearly about and
very deeply about it's like that the
Prime Minister will be challenged on
this but another way if you uh if you
don't want a slanging match you're
probably tuned into the wrong Channel I
think uh just the tone of the debate
that you just heard I think underlines
uh how people feel
um but if I could urge viewers to sort
of focus on one thing in this premise
questions a lot of the discussion is
about issues of principle and people
take different views but the most
interesting question for me is about
practicality is this legislation going
to hit the statute books are these new
laws going to come in any time soon does
the home office have the capacity to
deal with the extraordinary extra
workload that seems to be uh being
thrown their way into the department
that has had shall we say some problems
over time and then if people are going
to be removed from this country at PACE
at speed and at volume are we going to
have the deals in place to make it uh
possible to take them black quite what's
going to happen with the stroke I
thought the language around whether or
not Rwanda flights are going to start
again very fudgy uh from the government
yesterday it's not clear quite the
approach they're going to be taking in
relation to uh stressberg said whether
they can they feel they can go ahead
with those so I think there's quite a
lot of questions of detail uh and
practicality now premises questions not
always the moment where you see uh great
uh policy details Unearthed but let's
see how uh
domestic abuse
a lot of everything that we do Mr
Speaker this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Richard Berger thank you Mr
Speaker over a hundred days ago the
Prime Minister promised to publish his
tax returns he still hasn't people want
transparency in our politics especially
because the prime minister is the
richest prime minister in history and
because of the concerns they're ravine
so why on Earth hasn't the Prime
Minister published his tax returns yet
when will he do so and when he does so
will he include his U.S tax returns
Mr Speaker as I proved you friend I will
publish my tax returns and that will be
done very shortly
Mr Speaker on International women's day
can I congratulate the Prime Minister on
all the work that has been done on the
preventing sexual violence and conflict
initiative and ensure that the UK
continues to show its Global Leadership
uh Mr Speaker there are 250 000 people
in this country living on Park home
sites they are treated as second-class
Citizens by councils where they pay
council tax they are treated poorly by
managers who own the site and they are
at a disadvantage to when we'd roll out
our incredibly generous Energy's cubes
can the Prime Minister ensure that we
can actually give them more support and
more health and reform the homes Act
my honorable friend is right that there
is still more work to do to tackle
problems with the sector we are making
progress in implementing changes Mr
Speaker Park Homer's rights are now
codified in writing with the site owner
and should those obligations not be met
residents can take site owners to a
tribunal local authorities also now have
powers to take enforcement action and we
will continue to support them to improve
protection for Park home residents
everywhere no comes the leader of the
opposition Kirsten
uh thank you Mr Speaker and today on
Internationals women's day we celebrate
the successes of women in our society
it's a crying shame that as we do so we
Face legislation which drives a coach
and horses through our world-leading
modern slavery framework which protects
women from exploitation
Mr Speaker in the last decade this
government has introduced five plans to
tackle Illinois illegal immigration five
utter failures the problem just gets
worse with every new gimmick the Home
Secretary says the public are sick of
tough talk and inadequate action does he
agree with her assessment of this
government's record
[Applause]
Mr Speaker what the honorable gentleman
fails to recognize that
they are not alone in facing these
challenges and it is precisely because
it is precisely because that across
Europe the numbers escalating to the
extent they are we have brought forward
new plans because we are determined Mr
Speaker to ensure that this remains a
compassionate and generous country that
that is done fairly and legally
that's why we will break the criminal
gangs Mr Speaker we've announced new
agreements with Albania and France
tougher tougher immigration enforcement
and now new legislation that makes it
clear that if you come here illegally
you will be detained and swiftly removed
how does the honorable gentleman's plan
we know what it is it's open door
immigration
an unlimited Asylum whilst he may be on
the side of the people Smugglers we're
on the side of the British people
if he was serious about stopping the
boats he'd actually steal our plan on
stopping the boat smash the gangs sort
out the returns and clean up the utter
mess Mr Speaker
I'm good to hear this and nobody's going
to I wonder if I were you but
I think we've heard enough I want to
hear the questions and the answers and
they won't be interrupted Mr Speaker
nobody on this side of the house wants
open borders on that side they've lost
control of the body
now who's promised the country he's
promised the country that this bill will
stop all Small Boat Crossings now ifs no
buts sounds like more talk so in the
interest of adequate action when will he
achieve that
[Applause]
to The Honorable gentleman's support but
the reality is Mr Speaker on this issue
The Honorable gentleman has been on the
wrong side of this stuff prime minister
Mr Stafford if you don't want to hear
him you can go and have a good cup of
tea nice and strong I should say well I
will here in prime minister
The Honorable gentleman has been on the
wrong side of this issue his
he described all immigration law as
racist
said it was a mistake to control
immigration and he has never ever voted
for tougher Asylum laws it is clear Mr
Speaker while he's in Hawk to the open
border activist we're on the side of the
British people
Mr Speaker when I was in charge of
prosecutions I extradated countless
rapists
conviction rate for people smuggling was
twice what it is today
they voted against his legislation last
time because I said it wouldn't work
since it became law the numbers have
gone up he's proved me right he should
be apologizing not gloating
prime minister says they will detain
people who aren't eligible to claim
Asylum here and then return them well
they already tried that under the last
legislation last year 18 000 people were
deemed ineligible to apply for Asylum
that's the easy bit the talk but as for
the action prime minister how many of
them have actually been returned this
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker as as a result as
a result of the plans we brought forward
we have almost doubled the number of
people returned this year but he talks
about he talks about laws he talked
about
how's that I think the front bench needs
to be a little quieter because I want to
hear
you joining in I
have the importance this is questions
but the questions for the answers sure
where we could Stitcher is the respect
the Jew come on Mr Speaker he asked
us arrest he asked about our laws
actually when I was in
looking tomorrow law enforcement
officials what do they tell me precisely
because of the law that the conservative
government passed last year they have
now been able to arrest more than double
the number of people they did before
397 in the last six months but stopping
the boats Mr Speaker stopping the boats
is not just my priority it is the
people's priority but his position his
position on this is clear he wanted to
in his words scrap the Rwanda deal he
voted against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
oh
we'll continue when you keep shouting it
prolongs and some of you are trying to
catch my eye when you're disappointed I
don't want any complaints let's get
through these questions so we might get
some bike benching Mr Speaker all that
nonsense because he doesn't want to
answer the question because he knows
what the answer is the number is 21. I
thought it was a man of detail 21 21
people out of the 18
000 of what happens to the rest they sit
in hotels and digs for months on end of
the taxpayers expense last year he
promised to end the hotel fast that's
the talk but because of his mess there
are thousands of people who can't claim
Asylum and can't be returned so where
does he actually think they're going to
end up
Mr Speaker he talks about the pressure
on our Asylum system all right so
we've actually got a letter to plan to
stop people coming here in the first
place Mr Speaker let he labor labor have
absolutely no plan on this issue because
they simply don't want to tackle the
problem
we introduced we introduced tougher
sentences for people Smugglers they
opposed it we signed a deal with Rwanda
they opposed it we are deporting foreign
offenders as we speak they oppose it
I'm gonna say to the member from Hull
save that good voice for the rugby match
you might be able to join Mr Stafford
over that strong cup of tea prime
minister
speaker in fact he opposed every single
step of what we've done to try and stop
this problem in fact his only his only
contribution to this debate well we know
what it is
offend free movement that's the labor
party for you Mr Speaker
[Music]
Mr Speaker he stood there last year
saying exactly the same thing we said it
wouldn't work they passed the law the
numbers went up completely absolutely
deluded
he can't say where they'll return people
because they spent 140 million on Rwanda
and it doesn't work they can't say how
they'll return people because this bill
doesn't come with a single new return
agreement and they can't say when
they'll fix the mess because it's more
talk more gimmicks more promises to be
broken now a few months ago I put to him
that of the people who arrived on small
boats only four percent had been
processed he stood there and said that's
unacceptable
yeah what's the number down
as a result of what we've done there are
now 6 000 fewer people in the caseload
of Asylum backlog we're hiring more
caseworkers
speaker because we do have returns
agreements with India with Pakistan with
Serbia with Nigeria and crucially now
with Albania where we are returning
hundreds of people Mr Speaker but look
our position on this is clear if you
arrive here illegally you will not be
able to claim Asylum here you will not
be able to access the modern slavery
system and you will not be able to make
spurious human rights claims that is the
right thing to do but he's simply he's
going on and on about process hiding
behind process because he doesn't want
to confront the substance we are the
party of fairness and he represents the
party of free movement
okay I thought you were supposed to be
the man of detail he's gone to all
Outlets to avoid the detail he knows the
answer to the question less than one
percent for those arrived by boats have
been processed it shakes his head it's
the government's own statistic on his
watch on his watch processing of those
boat cases has gone from unacceptable in
his words to almost non-existence and
doesn't that tell you everything you
need to know after 13 years Small Boat
Crossings higher than ever claims
unprocessed the taxpayer paying for
hotel rooms criminal gangs running all
the way laughing to the bank and an
asylum says to utterly broken on his
watch this is their fifth prime minister
their sixth immigration plan their
seventh Home Secretary and after all
this time all they offer is the same old
gimmicks and empty promises I don't
agree with the homesick film very much
but when she says that the Tories are
all talk and no action she's spot on
isn't she
Mr Speaker
prime minister
Mr Speaker illegal immigration
enforcement up the amount of people
processing claims up the backlog is down
the number of returns agreements is up
new new hundreds of people returned to
Albania and now new laws to detain and
deter illegal migrants it's clear what
we stand for Mr Pica we're doing what's
right we're acting with compassion we
are acting with Learners and we are
acting to respect the laws and borders
of our country we are delivering what we
said and it's Crystal Clear listening to
this Mr Speaker it's going to be the
conservatives and only the conservatives
that stop the boat
graphic lessons on oral sex how to choke
your partner safely and 72 genders this
is what passes for relationships and sex
education in British schools across the
country children are being subjected to
lessons that are age inappropriate
extreme sexualizing and inaccurate often
using resources from unregulated
organizations that are actively
campaigning to undermine parents this is
not a victory for equality it is a
catastrophe for childhood will am I
right honorable friend honor his
commitment to end inappropriate sex
education by commissioning an
independent inquiry into the nature and
extent of this safeguarding scandal
can I say I I share my honorable friends
concerns and thank her for her work in
this area that's why I've asked a
department for education to ensure that
schools are not teaching inappropriate
or contested content in rshe our
priority should always be the safety and
well-being of children and schools
should also make curriculum content and
materials available to parents as a
result of all of this we are bringing
forward a review of rshe statutory
guidance and will consult and we'll
start our consultation as soon as
possible SMP leader Stephen Flint yeah
yeah Mr Speaker on International women's
day can I ask the prime minister to
reconfirm the under his proposed new
Asylum was a woman who is sex trafficked
to the UK on a small boat by a criminal
gang will not be afforded protection
under our modern slavery laws Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker it's precisely because we
want to Target our compassion and our
resources on the world's most vulnerable
people that we must get a grip of this
system and break can I just say to this
in peace quite right the questions are
asked but I also want to know the answer
shouting from up there is not helping
anybody prime minister Mr thik as I said
it's precisely because we want to Target
our resources and our compassion on the
world's most vulnerable people that we
need to get a grip of this system make
sure that we have control over our
borders make sure our our system and
resources are not over overwhelmed so
that we can help the people most in need
there is nothing Fair there is nothing
compassionate about sustaining a system
whereas we saw recently people are dying
on these crossings that is not right and
our plans will stop that from happening
Mr McDonald
I don't need to hear you chundering all
the way through you can be joining the
others for a cup of tea come on Stephen
please
Mr Speaker I'll take that as a yes from
the Prime Minister that women who are
the victims of sex trafficking will not
be protected under our modern slavery
laws what a complete and utter disgrace
Mr Speaker but whilst it means shock it
shouldn't necessarily surprise because
this is the Tory government in recent
months has spoken of invasions just
yesterday this was a Tory government
that said that 100 million people could
be coming to these shows and this is the
Tory government that this morning said
that number could in fact be billions
complete and utter nonsense so may I ask
the Prime Minister from whom or his
government taking inspiration Nigel
farage or Enoch Powell
for a load of nonsense now that in fact
the figure of 100 million it doesn't
come from the government it comes from
the United Nations Mr
s and it illustrates the scale tale of
the global migration crisis that the
world is grappling with which is why it
is right that we take action Mr Speaker
because if we do not the numbers will
continue to grow they have more than
quadrupled in just two years it's a sign
of what is to come and our system will
continue to be overwhelmed and if that
happens we will not be able to help the
people who are most in need of our
support our generosity and our
compassion this has always been the way
of this country and once we get a grip
of this system that's who we can extend
our support to and that's why it's the
right legislation
last year the UK economy grew at the at
the fastest rate in the G7 of 4.1
percent while at the same time
greenhouse gas emissions would fell by
3.4 more than comparable countries to
maintain this momentum ahead of the Net
Zero strategy refresh will he encourage
my right normal friend the chancellor to
use his budget statement next week to
stimulate invest in renewable energy
projects by renewable energy companies
both offshore and onshore to improve our
energy security reduce Reliance on more
expensive fossil fuels and ultimately
reduce bills for households
Mr Speaker I'm proud of our commitment
to scaling up renewable energy sources
Renewables make up now nearly 40 of our
electricity Supply a four-fold increase
since 2011. my honorable friend will
know that I uh cannot and will not
preempt budget decisions but he is a
powerful Champion for the environment in
this house and I've no doubt that he'll
make his no views known to the
chancellor Ed David
winning the tributes on International
women's day and pay a special tribute to
the women in this house past and present
who helped shape the future of our
country
Mr Speaker when Jean rang 999 she was
told she would have to wait at least
eight hours for an ambulance
so she got in her car and drove herself
to Eastbourne District General Hospital
she paid for parking and made it to the
entrance of a e where she collapsed
Gene died an hour later
Mr Speaker no one should lose their
mother or grandmother like that
so will the Prime Minister apologize to
Gene's family and to all those who've
lost loved ones due to the government's
appalling ambulance delays
well Mr Speaker of course my thoughts
and condolence go to Gene and Jean's
family for what's happened it's
absolutely right that we continue to
make progress on improving the
performance in Urgent emergency care we
outline plans to do this uh just the
other month and I'm pleased to say that
we are seeing performance improve
whether it's weights and a e or
ambulance performance times are
considerably marked improvement over the
last several weeks compared to the peak
pressures that we saw over the winter
due to covid and flu and because of the
Investments we're putting in in more
ambulances more doctors are nurses and
more discharge I'm confident that we
will continue to make progress to
getting the care that we all expect and
need to see
you thank you Mr Speaker
since its release earlier this year the
heartwarming and inspiring story of Dave
fish with journey to set up a community
bank has quickly risen to be one of
Netflix's top films last week in the
chamber I called for more initiatives
such as the bank of Dave to support
local communities across the UK does the
Prime Minister agree with me that
Financial inclusion is an essential part
of leveling up opportunities in our
communities and will he meet with me and
Dave to discuss how we can replicate his
success story in other areas such as
Stoke-on-Trent
will Mr Speaker Community focused Banks
and non-bank lenders like the Burnley
Savings and Loans have a vital role to
play in ensuring that everyone can
access Affordable Credit that's why
we've made it quicker and easier for new
Banks to enter the market and the new
bank startup unit was created several
years ago and now 30 new banks have been
authorized I will ensure that my
honorable friend gets the meeting with
the exchequer secretary to discuss this
issue further Kevin Brennan thank you Mr
Speaker BBC Radio 4's you and yours have
exposed Q jumping online touts who've
been buying up Eurovision tickets and
putting them on sale for thousands of
pounds on dodgy sites like via GoGo in
this year when we are hosting Eurovision
on behalf of War ravaged Ukraine this
latest example of rampant rip-off uh
culture in Tory Britain is particularly
particularly
despicable why hasn't his government
done more to support why isn't this
government do more to support genuine
fans
over the rip-off merchants the spibs and
their ticket tax yeah well Mr Speaker
actually we will continue we have we
have put in place measures to combat
ticket touting I'm happy to look at the
the documentary that he mentioned and
make sure that we're doing everything we
can do and I'll talk to the Home
Secretary about it but more generally it
is a source of enormous Pride for us to
host Eurovision I know it's something
that everyone is looking forward to and
we should ensure that there is the
broadest possible access to seeing that
and we'll do everything we can to make
sure that that happens David Davis yeah
yeah Mr Speaker in the aftermath of 9 11
the British government signed an
extradition treaty with the United
States the intention of covering
terrorism and violent crime
this came into force in 2003 the U.S has
extraded 83 people that hit to the UK
we've sent 225 to America and three
quarters of those would be the
non-violent and largely White Collar
alleged crimes there's a fundamental
unfairness at the heart of our
Expedition treaty and it was shown by
the fact that Anna sakulis refused to
come to face trial for the killing of
Harry Dunn the unfair treaty is
compounded by an American system which
coerces British citizens and gives them
an unfair trial and the last two years
at the last two decades the uh the
American policy has been rather like an
international commercial policy will the
correcting this is important will the
Prime Minister look at this treaty with
a view to correcting this parody of
Justice
well Mr Mr Speaker I thank the my
honorable friend for his question
obviously it's in our natural interests
to have effective extradition
relationships and under the treaty we
have with the us we've secured the
extradition and subsequent conviction of
terrorists murderers rapists and child
sex offenders um I'm happy to meet with
him to discuss this issue further as he
knows the the U.S has refused I think
one UK extradition and the UK uh out of
that sort of the US's reviews one UK
Expedition request and the UK has
refused 27 but I know that he has
concerns and I'll be happy to meet him
to discuss this further mccaskill thank
you Mr Speaker there's a stark
correlation between areas of the gas
grid and those with the highest rates of
fuel poverty it's worse in Scotland
ironically in those areas closest to the
national gas reserves in the North Sea
but also an urban deprived areas where
multi-story flats are deprived of the
ability of having natural gas being off
the gas grid means that you're dependent
on currently unregulated fuels such as
heating oil that have risen who are
faster than electricity and gas or being
dependent upon old and inefficient and
very costly all-electric systems will
the Prime Minister end this by ensuring
that all fuels are regulated and also by
ensuring that these households that are
all electric are able to get the
alternative fuel payment
this is because someone who represents a
rural constituency with many people off
gas grade I appreciate the concern The
Honorable gentleman raises but that's
why that's always been uppermost in the
government's mind as if we as we've
designed and implemented our support for
people with energy bills notably doing
that based on electricity meters rather
than gas but also putting in place the
alternative fuel support payment of 200
pounds and we're making sure that that
gets to everyone who needs it Richard
bacon Mr Speaker the adjustments to the
dental contract last November were a
very welcome step but there is more work
to do we'll lead prime minister
therefore keep this area under the very
closest review to ensure that
constituents such as mine in the South
Norfolk and those of other honorable
members get the best possible Dental
Care
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend
raises an excellent point and I can tell
them that we are continuing to invest in
NHS Dentistry 3 billion pounds a year
but we've also enabled practice this to
do 10 more activity on top of their
contracts and remove the barriers so
that hygienists and other therapists can
continue to work to their full skill set
the number of NHS Dentures has increased
by about 500 over last year and will
continue to work with the sector to see
what more we can do
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker as today is
international women's day does the Prime
Minister agree with me that voters in
the run-up to May's local elections have
every right to ask candidates who are
standing for a position of
responsibility in local government
questions relating to women's rights and
does he believe that as representatives
of their political parties all
candidates must answer those questions
honestly politely and with respect while
standing on a voter's doorstep
well Mr Speaker the uh The Honorable
lady makes an excellent point and I
wholeheartedly agree with her the these
are important questions voters deserve
to have clear and straightforward
answers to them and I hope that she can
continue to put her campaign forward
she'll have my full support and I hope
in the local elections we can debate
these issues in the way that they should
be Chris Watts thank you Mr Speaker last
weekend I had the pleasure of being
auctioned off for the conservative
women's organization
[Applause]
on this International women's day will
my right-honorable friend uh join me in
paying tribute to the excellent work the
cwo do to get more women conservative
women into politics and pay and pay
tribute to all the remarkable women who
support us in the work we do especially
because she's in the gallery by month
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
can I congratulate first of all my
honorable friend for his successful
auction
um I assume it I I assume it wasn't his
it wasn't his mother but bid for him
successfully uh but also uh pay tribute
to her uh but also pay tribute to the
work of the conservative women's
Organization for them fantastic work
they do we need more uh women standing
in local and National politics and
everyone who is working to bring that
about deserves our praise and thanks and
long may it continue
thank you Mr Speaker on today's
International women's day uh research
published by pensions company Scottish
widows has shown that uh a woman
retiring today would have to work to the
age of 81 to achieve a pension fund
party with a real counterpart and that's
what everybody is worrying a woman in
the workplace today age 25 can still
expect to retire with a pension fund a
hundred thousand pounds on average
counterparts with all of the fiscal and
social policy levers at his disposal can
the Prime Minister tell us how he is
going to set a course to shut that Gap
over what remains of his Premiership
well Mr Speaker the government takes the
issue of the gender pensions Gap
incredibly seriously and we've delivered
groundbreaking pension reforms and major
progress automatic enrollment has in
fact helped Millions more women save
into the pension and pensions
participation among eligible women in
the private sector was 87 percent in the
last of able year up from just 40 a few
years ago and we remain committed to the
measures in the 2017 review and will
continue to give this issue all the
attention it deserves until we can close
the gap
thank you Mr Speaker
Grimsby Town Football Club has reached
the quarterfinals
the last time the team achieved that was
in 1939 that by coincidence was the
previous time that the town had a
conservative MP
now now I know now I know that Grimsby
beats the prime minister's team of
Southampton to get to this next stage
but would he join with me in
congratulating the team and wishing the
best of luck when they uh play against
Brighton hope Albion in the next stage
uh Miss uh Mr Mr Mr Speaker
it pains me although uh I will I will
say congratulations to the honorable
lady Anne Grimsby uh for their victory
over Southampton and I now have a new
team to support in the cup and she'll
have mindful support I wish them well
against their next match and look
forward to cheering her and all her
colleagues on Steve McKay
Mr Speaker of healthy prime minister
talk fondly about helping out in his
mom's Community Pharmacy how will we
feel if 600 of them closed this year
because of a vicious NHS contract which
takes no account of rising gods and is
forcing many into bankruptcy
Mr a speaker I praise the work that our
community pharmacies do they're
fantastic at being on the front line of
delivering primary care and as I've said
previously the government is exploring
ways in which we can support them to do
even more because I think improving
access to pharmacies is something that
people would both welcome and would help
people get the care that they need
faster and more efficiently and we'll
continue to look at all the proposals
that have been given to us
[Applause]
legal waste site has been operating in
the village of Boston Tipper lorries
covering their number plates as they
Thunder onto the site at all hours of
the day and night blighting the lives of
the residents that live directly by and
creating Untold environmental damage I
thank the defra team for their
engagement with the environment agency
so far but no action has been taken so
does my right honorable friend agree
with me that enough is enough and Swift
multi-agency action should be taken to
stop and shut down illegal and criminal
activity such as this
uh well can I thank my right honorable
friend for raising this issue the
government is committed to tackling
waste crime and the joint unit for Waste
crime brings together agencies in the
way that she described I am aware she's
met the local environment agency
director about this particular issue but
I will also ensure that she gets a
meeting with a relevant minister to
discuss this further but Robert thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker my constituent
Ollie Stevens was just 13 years old when
he was stabbed and brutally murdered in
a local park just yards from his home
two boys who attacked him had shared
dozens of pictures of knives online
before the attack
so could the Prime Minister explain to
me why the government's removed measures
to tackle this sort of dreadful online
content from the online safety bill
thank you well Mr Speaker I'm very sorry
to hear about the case that The
Honorable gentleman raises my thoughts
are with Ollie's family uh he's
absolutely right that we should do
everything we can to tackle the scourge
of knife crime and that's why for
instance this government brought forward
new powers to improve the police's use
of stop and search which has made a
major difference in actually violent
crime is now down considerably uh over
the past few years the Online safety
Bill also goes further than any other
country has gone to make sure that we
are protecting Children online I'm happy
to look at the specific issues that he
mentions but it's been praised by the
children's commissioner and others for
being a groundbreaking groundbreaking
law that will do wonders to improve
children's safety the little touches
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
Secretary of State for defra will be
visiting Shrewsbury at the end of this
month at my invitation and she will hear
the tremendous progress to date from the
river 7 partnership and the environment
agency that we are working to try to
find a holistic solution to managing
Britain's longest river the river seven
we are now experiencing flooding in
Shrewsbury on an annual basis with
tremendous economic damage as a result
will he take an interest please and
secure additional funding for defra so
that we can finally tame these rivers
and protect our communities from annual
flooding
this is an issue that my honorable
friend has raised before and he's right
to do so the government has doubled
flooding for double investment in flood
defenses over this Parliament over 5.2
billion pounds I know the defra
secretary uh will have her visit we'll
talk to him and his communities and I
look forward to hearing back from her
after that
Joe Jones Thank you Mr Speaker between
1997 and 2010 labor governments across
the UK lifted 800 000 children out of
poverty
since 2010 the conservatives have driven
half a million children into poverty
with child poverty next year predicted
to reach levels not seen since the 1990s
there is not enough parliamentary time
this year for the prime minister to say
sorry to each child damaged by their
policies but could the Prime Minister
start today by saying sorry for all the
children that he failed during this time
well Mr Speaker the exact that's all
since since 2010 there are 1.2 million
fewer people in poverty uh than there
were and that's because of the actions
that this conservative government has
been putting in place like raising the
national living wage which by the way Mr
Speaker the best way to ensure that
children especially do not grow up in
poverty is to ensure that they are not
growing up in a workless household and
as a result of the actions of this
government are getting people into work
there are now several thousand fewer
workless households than in 2010. that's
the outfit
[Applause]
talk about the work he's undertaking on
the pull factors to tackle illegal
immigration the Prime Minister has a
meeting upcoming with President macron
this week could I ask him to see what
more can be done to deal with the push
factors of illegal migration around
school votes particularly pushing those
boats across French beaches and pushing
those boats from French Beaches into the
French sea
it's the speaker as I said for there is
no there is no single lever that will
solve this problem which is right that
we work on all the different things that
will make a difference including close
cooperation with the French that's why I
was pleased at the end of last year the
Home Secretary and I announced the
largest ever small boats deal with
France 40 increase in Patrol it's
greater cooperation and we look forward
to strengthening that cooperation and
furthering that discussion this Friday
Mr Speaker let us be absolutely clear in
this chamber under this government's new
dystopian far-right appeasing anti
Refugee Bill
those
those who were trafficked keep going
those who were trafficked to the UK
would still face deportation can the
Prime Minister therefore clear up
whether sir more father who last year
bravely revealed that he was trafficked
to the UK as a child would have been
removed under this bill
Mr Mr Speaker it's precisely because
that we do want to help the world's most
vulnerable people that we've got to stop
that we've got to stop our system being
exploited and overwhelmed by illegal
migrants who are being trafficked here
by criminal gangs there is nothing
compassionate there is nothing fair
about supporting that system continued
continuing and that's why our new laws
are the right way to deal with this and
I hope that he can see that and support
them
thank you Mr Speaker this morning on
International women's day I joined some
of the amazing young women at Our Lady
of Lord's School in Leon sea to take
part in the fa's let girls play football
does my right honorable friends agree
that Sport and football in particular is
a brilliant way to empower young women
and what he visits South End and
celebrate some of our aspiring lionesses
well Mr Speaker Marvel friend makes an
excellent point I wholeheartedly agree
with her hopefully I can come and visit
her she's right about the power of sport
to both engage young women but also to
inspire others I'm looking forward to
seeing the lionesses later today and the
government is pleased to announce today
more funding and more support for sport
and scores which I hope she will warmly
welcome final question to here Ali
[Applause]
on International women's day it is vital
we talk about women in Indian occupied
Kashmir being subjected to rape domestic
abuse kidnapping forced marriage and
torture by the prime minister's Moody's
extremist BJP LED government does the
Prime Minister agree with me that the
BJP government have exploited women
through gender-based violence and does
he agree that the UK government should
be standing in solidarity with kashmiri
women yeah yeah speaker this this
government has a proud record of
standing up for women and girls across
the world we have led the way in
preventing sexual violence in conflict
and we're taking a lead on ensuring tens
of millions of girls receive the high
quality education that they deserve in
some of the poorest parts of the world
and just today we have announced a new
women and girls strategy from the
foreign office and back that up with 200
million pounds more to support Women's
Health around the world and that
continues our leadership on this issue
which will remain the case
well that they're the end of prime
minister's questions a little bit of
breaking news before we dissect it with
uh Sam Coates we've been hearing the
last few minutes that the Duke and
Duchess of sussex's daughter Princess
lilibit Diana has been christened
christened last Friday by the Archbishop
of Los Angeles it's the first time uh
that the daughter they refer to as Lily
has been publicly referred to as
Princess and she became a princess when
her grandfather the king
succeeded to the throne
so lots to chew over with prime
minister's questions and our Deputy
political editor Sam coats is here in
the studio Sam migration was expected to
dominate and it certainly did that's
right Jane I I actually thought it was a
fascinating pmqs not because of the
facts that were Unearthed during it
about migration most of those if you've
been paying attention to the government
announcement yesterday a sort of broadly
in the public domain but we sort of
learned a lot about how politics around
this issue is going to be conducted and
I thought it was really interesting just
to observe the different approaches of
the two party leaders so what Rishi CNAC
was doing was trying to emphasize the
principles here the he was trying to
mind the divisions between the
conservative position as outlined by him
and the Home Secretary Sola bravaman
over the last 48 hours and the labor
position which is slightly less distinct
in certain uh certain ways so uh so
Rishi sunak did policy
kirstama did process he tried to focus
on whether the plans were deliverable he
sidestepped really what he agreed with
and what he didn't agree with and
instead he focused on whether Whitehall
was fit for us whether the government
had a good track record on uh delivering
these kind of policies in the past and
whether or not in practice it's all
going to work out now that what that
wasn't the only route he could have gone
down if you listen to the SNP uh
Westminster Lydia Stephen Flynn he he
attacked Rishi sunak on the basis of uh
policy he suggested that a woman who had
been trafficked came over on a small
boat would be subject to immediate
deportation and never be allowed to
claim asylum in this country he
suggested that the principle is unfair
but instead kestarma went all on whether
or not this was going to make any
practical difference so just hear a bit
of kirst armor
after 13 years Small Boat Crossings
higher than ever claims unprocessed the
taxpayer paying for hotel rooms criminal
gangs running all the way laughing to
the bank and an asylum sister utterly
broken on his wall this is their fifth
prime minister their sixth immigration
plan their seventh Home Secretary and
after all this time all they offer is
the same old gimmicks and empty promises
I don't agree with the home sector on
very much but when she says that the
Tories are all talk and no action she's
spot-on isn't she
so you had a number of uh facts that
kirstama wheeled out four percent of uh
claims processed now that's down uh to
less than one percent uh and I think he
highlighted uh the number of people who
have been returned under the previous
Asylum system that the government had
run
um so that was uh Kirsten's uh plan of
attack Rishi Cenex well we learned a lot
there as well effectively this is going
to be an election dividing line you
could tell from the way that the Prime
Minister I mean bluntly threw the
kitchen sink at this one trying to
highlight all sorts of uh previous
things that kirst armor has said about
migration basically making him out to be
in favor of open borders uh and then
rolling out this attack line uh of being
a lefty lawyer I thought Rishi sunax
contribution had all of the smell all of
the Hallmarks of being carefully focused
grouped designed to try and road test
some of the language that we'll hear it
all the way up to the election
suggesting it has to be said Jane uh
that this is as much if not more about
politics than it is every given the
tight time frame between now and the
next general election given it's going
to take months and months and months for
the legislation to pass politics here's
how Rishi sunak uh through the kitchen
sink at kiss Dharma
foreign
talking to our law enforcement officials
what do they tell me precisely because
of the law that the conservative
government passed last year they have
now been able to arrest more than double
the number of people they did before
397 in the last six months but stopping
the boats Mr Speaker stopping the boats
is not just my priority it is the
people's priority but his position he
position on Mrs Claire he wanted to in
his words scrap the Rwanda deal he voted
against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
foreign
again and again on the run-up to the
election someone else would be learned
at pmqs a couple of issues that emerged
on the side
um most strikingly uh a conservative MP
Miriam Cates asked the Prime Minister on
International women's day about uh
whether or not all schools were teaching
uh or some schools were teaching
inappropriate information or graphic
including graphic descriptions of oral
sex as part of sex education lessons and
the Prime Minister actually said that
he's asked the department for education
to ensure that children are not getting
information that is not age appropriate
so it sounds like there's been an
announcement of a decision of a
government action that we didn't know
about in relation to sex education he
said he's bringing forward a review on
psh and uh so something uh to watch
there for uh interesting uh what's
behind that um what evidence they have
and what action is going to take be
taken about that and also right at the
start of prime minister's questions in
response to a question from Richard
Bergen the left-wing labor mp uh
he'll be releasing his tax returns soon
so that's one two uh watch for one for
Donald Trump torch as well perhaps
thanks very much son
now Ukraine has denied reports that it
was behind the Nordstrom pipeline attack
after U.S intelligence suggested a pro
Kiev group was responsible Russia has
repeatedly denied involvement in the
incident last year and blamed the West
as America and NATO called the incident
an act of sabotage
for me it's a little bit strange story
because it's not this story is nothing
with us and I think that investigation
of official authorities will describe
every details because it's like a
compliment for our special forces but
this is not our activity
all this I'm joined by our defense and
security analyst Professor Michael Clark
who's in our other glass box studio and
Michael there's an old stream mystery
does seem to be rolling on doesn't it
have we learned much more today
uh not really Jane I mean I think the
story rests on only sort of two threads
quite thin threads really one is that
there's a lot of Investigations going on
so the UN is investigating European
governments are investigating this
explosion and the United States is
investigating it and one part of one of
the U.S investigations was leaked
apparently to the New York Times the New
York Times just running with it saying
that this was a bit of private
Enterprise on behalf of apparently some
Ukrainian or possibly Russian dissidents
there's a bit more of a strong thread
with um Desai to the German designed an
ARD in Germany are reporting that a
group with false passports charted a
boat in Poland sailed it to rostock then
to Christianity Island which is near
where the explosions happened and they
had divers on board six of them they had
two divers two assistants whatever
they're supposed to do and when the boat
came back and was handed back it was a
higher boat there were traces of
explosions